the dream of the 90s is alive on Netflix
but how does that 90s show connect to
its 70s set counterpart here's all you
need to know during its eight season run
from 1998 to 2006 That 70s Show became a
flagship series for Fox nostalgic but
not overly sentimental fans and critics
were enamored with the show's easy
lived-in sense of humor and the reliable
Chemistry Between the foreman family and
the gaggle of teens who hung out in
their Wisconsin basement in 2002 Fox
tried to capture the That 70s Show magic
again with that 80s Show starring Glenn
Howerton a future It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia Fame the ill-fated series
was canceled after one season Now That
70s Show is getting its first proper
spin-off with that 90s show here's
everything we know about the upcoming
Netflix series in November Netflix
dropped the first teaser trailer for
that 90s show the minute long spot shows
red and Kitty as the stewards to a new
group of teenagers okay kids the
basement is all yours Kitty is just as
cheery as ever and red hasn't lost his
Gruff disposition either impressively
the foreman house is essentially stuck
in time with the same 70s set pieces
littered throughout the home including
Red's pea green chair and the basement's
sturdy spool table the 90s set show may
include some developments in fashion
goodbye bell bottoms hello plaid but the
trailer suggests that team behavior is
timeless indeed the teens can be seen
enjoying a keg on the Water Tower and
participating in the fabled Smoke Circle
the teaser doesn't give any insight into
what the original stars are up to but
with that 90s show set to Premiere in a
few short weeks they might make an
appearance in an upcoming full-length
trailer as the title suggests that 90s
show takes place in the summer of 1995
though the period will be new the
location will be very familiar to fans
of That 70s Show which took place
between 1976 and 1979. the spin-off
follows Leia Foreman Eric and Donna's 15
year old daughter as she spends the
summer at her grandparents house in
Point Place there Leia meets her
next-door neighbor Gwen and Gwen's group
of friends who happily set up shop in
the Foreman's basement according to each
season of that 90s show will take place
during the following summer as the
series resident adults red and kitty
Foreman will have a new crew of
teenagers to coddle intimidate and
Mentor co-creator Lindsey Turner told
variety what was really key early on was
talking about who red and kitty became
in the quiet after the kids left and how
did the kids coming back change that how
has it reawakened pieces of them how
have they changed how are they the same
that 90s show comes from Bonnie and
Terry Turner the creators of That 70s
Show they brought in Greg metler a
former writer on That 70s Show to act as
showrunner and the three of them plus
the Turner's daughter Lindsay
conceptualized the new series Kurt wood
Smith and Deborah Joe Rupp also joined
the creative team as executive producers
metler told variety I wanted to have the
same feeling as That 70s Show did the
show had a very special tone it was
playful it had a heart it was sarcastic
it was filled with love within this
family within the friend group I missed
being in the basement with those kids
Netflix officially announced a 10
episode order of that 90s show and after
October of 2021 but the buzz of a reboot
had been circulating for years according
to deadline before leaving Netflix in
2020 That 70s Show Drew impressive
numbers for the streamer the series was
reportedly one of Netflix's highest
performing sitcoms that year and the
streaming service was eager to bring
back viewers in the form of a reboot by
the end of 2020 the idea for that 90s
show had gained a foothold at Netflix
production on that 90s show began in
early 2022 though the series takes place
in Wisconsin it was filmed at the sunset
Bronson Studios in Hollywood in front of
a live studio audience fans can ring in
2023 with that 90s show when it hits
Netflix on January 19th